Guys, really quick as we wrap up this module on content, I want to talk about outsourcing
really quick.
And a lot of you guys, I know it's like, oh my gosh, content, it's the worst, it sucks.
Back to what I said.
This is one of those areas, if we can get good at it, if we can master it, this is going
to give us that edge over the competition.
So again, change your mindset from this is a burden to how do I master it, how do I get
good at it.
And that segues perfectly into when should you outsource your content.
It's the same answer as when you should outsource anything after you master it.
If you do not know how to write content yourself, how are you going to outsource it?
How are you going to know that the person that you gave it to wrote good content?
How are you going to know that they didn't plagiarize it?
How are you going to know that it's decent content?
You're not unless you personally know how to write it and you're not going to be able
to know how to train on it.
Number one, don't start or try to outsource something until you first have mastered it.
We are going to be coming out with some resources if you decide that you want to start outsourcing
content in the future, but for now go master it and let's go rank these websites.